après une année difficile qui ne
couvrait pas les charges des producteurs
de lait la laiterie de verneuil reprend
du poil de la bête
le prix du lait de vache a été
revalorisé de 20% depuis 2016 mais en
s'appuyant sur une base très faible qui
permet tout juste aux producteurs de
survivre pour assurer sa pérennité
la coopérative s'appuie désormais sur
d'autres produits vendus plus chers
comme le lait de chèvre + 60 % de ventes
en 2016 il ya une reprise de la
consommation
il ya eu aussi une baisse des
importations de lait de chèvre et donc
nous à notre niveau
nos producteurs ont repris un petit peu
la production parce que la valorisation
a aussi été meilleur lorsqu'il leur a
permis de remplir les bâtiments et
d'avoir un peu plus de chair autre coup
de pouce la hausse de 80% du prix du
beurre sur le marché mondial ici s'en
fabrique de 1500 tonnes par an cela
représente 20% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel de la coopérative le prix de
sous-produits du beurre qui est le lait
écrémé et très bas donc au global le
prix du beurre est bon mais on a ce
sous-produit qu'il faut quand même
valorisé et sur lequel n'est pas du tout
sur la même position alors qu'il ya eu
une période en 2013 et début de 2014 ou
là à la fois le prix du beurre et le
prix de la poudre était élevé le bios y
participent à la relance de l'industrie
laitière comme pour le lait de chèvre
il est stocké collecté et transformé
différemment un cahier des charges qui
entraîne quelques surcoût mais pour
lequel le consommateur est prêt à mettre
le prix